-Welcome back, Andrew.
How are you?
-I'm good. How are you?
-I'm very good.
It is very nice to see you
You've been a frequent guest
on our show.
-Yep.
-So it's a little surreal
talking to you virtually.
-I think this is
my seventh time.
I got to say, Seth,
I was telling your producers
the other day,
you and your whole staff
are just nailing this.
-Oh, thank you, buddy.
-And it's such a --
it's such a great comfort
to watch your show
and to see what you're doing
And I just -- You know,
I've always been a fan,
but particularly
in the past few months.
You guys are just doing
such a fantastic job.
-That's so kind of you to say.
And I can tell you that it is --
I feel such comfort
being able to do it.
So thank you for watching.
So this -- You're airing the
final four episodes, correct
Because you guys --
You did finish in time,
but then COVID interrupted
post-production.
-Exactly.
So we have four episodes left.
So that next episode
will air this Sunday.
Yeah, we had it all filmed
but then, you know,
there's a lot of work
that needs to be done
in post with editing and ADR
and things like that.
So we had to take
a little pause,
and now we're
kicking back up again.
And we're starting off with --
I think it's one of my favorit
episodes of the season because
it's a Halloween episode.
-Yeah.
-Which was my favorite as a kid,
like, watching those episode
where everybody gets dressed u
in crazy costumes.
And I sort of strong-armed
our creators into letting me
dress up as George Michael
from the "Faith" video.
-And it's era-appropriate
to the show.
-Yes, no.
Totally appropriate, within --
Yes, I think
it's very appropriate.
But I just wanted professional
to make me look like
George Michael.
-Yeah.
-Sort of --
-You -- By the way,
we have some photos,
and they did a very good job
But you were close.
Like, you can't just make anyone
look like George Michael.
You did a lot of work here
-Well, thank you.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, no, I was --
I was very excited,
but everybody else sort of had
like -- They were giving
other options and things.
And I was like,
"That's the only one I want.
I want to look like George
Michael in the 'Faith' video
cause I always have wanted
to look like that."
-I love that video a great deal.
I don't know at that time if
I knew George Michael was gay.
Was he out then?
Or probably not.
-No. I don't think he came out
until like probably
ten years later or so.
-Gotcha.
-Like, in my little child heart,
I knew that there was
a kinship there.
-Yeah.
Whereas I just thought,
"That is the coolest guy
I've ever seen."
-Cool guy. Cool guy.
-I mean, he --
And, by the way, I was right
He is the coolest guy
I'd ever seen.
I just wasn't getting --
I was missing a good deal of i
I think at the time.
-I think, but you weren't alone.
I think a lot of people
were missing that, so...
-And did you -- When you
were wearing the outfit,
was it exactly as rewardin
as you wanted it to feel?
-Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, I spent a lot of tim
just, like, looking at mysel
in the mirror being like..
-[ Laughs ]
Your character --
And I know you to be a good guy.
And I feel like, on the whole,
you've played nice people.
Your character
is a very bad person now.
-Yeah, yeah.
The first season was sort of -
He was sort of naive
and kind of, you know,
figuring out his place
on Wall Street.
And then the second season he'
really just gone off the rails
I mean, he's -- I would
read these scripts and be like
"you want me to do what?"
So it was really fun
to get to do
because it was so differen
from the first season.
And we had -- Yeah, there wa
a lot to cover this season
And I got -- You know, I hav
both a wife and a boyfriend.
-Yeah.
-So that's always very exciting.
And my boyfriend this season
is played by my actual
boyfriend, Tuc Watkins,
so that was also a real treat.
We met doing "Boys in the Band
on Broadway
and then had filmed the movie of
"Boys in the Band" for Netflix
And then we got to work together
on "Black Monday."
So it's very nice.
It's very nice working --
-So, tell me, 'cause I would
imagine sex scenes are very hard
when it's someone you're not
a couple with in real life
-Yeah.
-But are they actually easie
when it's someone you're
a couple with in real life
or is it still so not --
Since it's so public, I guess?
-Well, you know,
having done both now,
I would say that the anxiety
is just a little --
It's a new kind of anxiety
Because I've done --
Like, on "Girls,"
like, I had to do a handfu
of sex scenes and a few with
Corey Stoll, who's so fantastic,
but we didn't really know
each other,
so that was very awkward
to sort of figure out, like,
"What are you comfortable with
and is this okay
and how do I touch you?"
So, with Tuc, it was very easy
to sort of block it
and get into it.
But then when it came time
to actually filming it,
all of a sudden
I had this realization
that I was surrounded
by the crew,
who have now become
friends of mine,
and I thought,
"I wonder if they're thinking,
'So that's what it looks like.
That's what they do at home.
That's how they touch
each other.'"
So then I got sort of, like,
weirdly self-conscious
in a different way.
But all that said,
it was much easier to do i
With, you know, somebody that...
-Right.
-Yeah.